parents of students at desert oasis high
school are speaking out after their
principal has been replaced that's right
well some say they're not surprised
following a rash of incidents madison
kimbrough is live at the campus and
madison i understand you also spoke
briefly to the former principal
i called to speak to her about what
happened but she declined to comment
however parents here at desert oasis
very vocal making it clear that the
blame for what's been going on goes much
deeper than what they believe the
principal was able to handle
i just wish we would have had a little
bit more notice than one day
maybe a meeting
a vote on thursday desert oasis high
school parents were alerted by email of
a leadership change on campus in the
email it did not mention principal
jennifer beaudecker's name but did say
that her role as desert oasis principal
would change hands to that of ian
salzman who has served over 15 years
within the district as interim principal
until they find a permanent replacement
it's still unclear if principal bodecker
was asked to step down removed or
decided to leave on her own but with the
recent incidents at desert oasis the
consensus is that more change needs to
be done and whether replacing the
principal will make a difference or not
parents weigh in i don't think the
violence is 100 percent her fault when
do we hold our parents accountable it's
a lot to put on a principle i mean it
comes down to i think it's
i think it's a two-way street regardless
of how you look at it you know a
principal is the one that's on site
that's the face you see the face you
deal with i mean yell at them screaming
them you know you can't touch them can't
do anything to them and they know that
so
what do you do desert oasis has been
placed on two consecutive lockdowns in
march regarding a weapon being brought
to campus and fights at school one of
which involved an adult it just feels
like there was enough connection between
students and staff like everyone can try
better to just you know like be nicer
teacher and be nice to your students
it's one of those like kind of even
trade even respect kind of things
while desert oasis has had several
incidents reported the entirety of the
district has seen an influx of violent
behavior with over 5 300 cases this year
alone we reached out to the teachers
union for a statement we have yet to
hear back reporting live near desert
oasis madison kimbrough live local now